more than anywhere else in his hometown
Progresso Emiliano Salah was a hero here
the footballers death has hit hardest
affecting those of all ages throughout
the day people came to say goodbye
some clutching the number 9 shirt he
wore on the pitch San Martin was his
first team and inside the clubhouse
they placed his coffin beside a crucifix
surrounded by floral wreaths his father
and mother soft sister Romina
overwhelmed by the emotion sallet never
got the chance to play for Cardiff but
manager Neil Warnock and chief executive
kanchu traveled to pay their respects
the daffodil of Wales pinned to their
chests I told the mother a few 1 or 2
funny stories the Emiliano and myself
discussed when he came over and we had a
little bit of a laugh about it about his
clothes etc which mother was quite proud
of him obviously here too was Willi
Makai the agents who organized the plane
which crashed into the scene on January
21st and amid the morning there was
anger a family member of salak
questioning why the footballer was put
on that particular aircraft personally I
think Emilio know was killed yes he was
killed
there were many irregularities many
irregularities took place from the start
from when they sent a plane that wasn't
in good condition to cross the channel
with a pilot without experience the
weather wasn't good it was night and he
was alone there were many people
responsible the justice system will take
care of it the leafy town of Progresso
with its small Park and palm trees is
home only to around 3,000 people the
main business here is agriculture the
selling of soya and corn but there's no
doubt that Emiliano Salo became their
most successful export
here they are bewildered about how
exactly the dream ended and why it her
little gear is something I do not
understand and accept because it hurts
so much the town died my town died on
21st of January the pictures where
Emiliano Sala learned to play empty as
an entire town bid farewell Martha
Kellner skynews Progresso